Joe Biden publicly admitting the border
is not secure while actively trying to
make it less secure I don't know what
you call this a rogue executive branch
engaged in criminal activities Accused
by Texas the second largest state in the
Union of violating the
law now we have videos let me see if I
can uh uh pull up one of these these
videos here there's the uh the letter
here we go take a look at this from
Chuck kesto the Texas National Guard
filmed marching where I can only I
believe this is near Eagle Pass it just
says Texas National Guard and uh there
have been many responses to this in fact
I believe we have the uh Governor Kevin
stit of Oklahoma saying Oklahom stands
with Texas Ronda santis of course said
if the Constitution really made States
powerless to defend themselves against
an invasion it wouldn't have been
ratified in the first place and Texas
would have never joined the union when
it did